December's almost here, Santa Claus will be
taking to the skies, and he won't be alone:
Along with the reindeer doing all the work
pulling his sleigh, the skies are going to
be crowded with spaceships and balloons thanks
to Amazon Prime Video.
For most movie fans, Felicity Jones is likely
best remembered as the reluctant hero Jyn
Erso in 2016's Rogue One: A Star Wars Story.
On December 6, she'll be taking a trip back
to the 19th century to become a pilot in the
Amazon original film The Aeronauts.
Jones plays daredevil pilot Amelia Wren.
Accompanied by James Glaisher, played by Eddie
Redmayne, Wren takes to the sky via balloon
in hopes of making new discoveries in the
clouds.
The pair run into trouble on one of their
airborne journeys and, rather than discovering
new science, they find themselves in a fight
to survive.
The Aeronauts is fiction, but boasts some
solid footing in actual history.
While Wren is a purely fictional character,
James Glaisher was a real meteorologist working
in the 19th century.
Based on the bestselling series of novels
by Daniel Abraham and Ty Franck, The Expanse
premiered on Syfy to critical and commercial
success in 2015.
The series follows a crew of antiheroes who
uncover a vast conspiracy during a time when
humanity has colonized the stars.
Unfortunately, Syfy announced The Expanse's
third season would be its last in May 2018.
Thankfully for fans, Amazon Prime Video stepped
up to give the acclaimed series a new home.
The show's third season ended with the crew
of the Rocinante traveling through the Ring
Gate to an entirely new region of space.
All the surviving characters of the previous
season will be returning, but The Expanse
will have some new faces as well.
Lyndie Greenwood joins the cast as Dr. Elvin
Okoye, a UN scientist sent to explore a new
planet.
Burn Gorman will appear as Adolphus Murtry,
a man who wants to be the top dog on the new
planet and doesn't care what he has to do
to make that happen.
"Someday I think you and I are going to end
up bloody."
Amazon Prime Video is bringing plenty of action
flicks to the streaming service in December,
including a couple that are more than meets
the eye.
When it comes to its superhero fare, Prime
Video is going outside the box.
As of Dec. 1, subscribers can watch 2008's
Hancock, in which Will Smith plays a deadbeat
guy with Superman-like powers who has to figure
out how to be a genuine hero.
On December 11, subscribers can watch 2018's
Fast Color, starring Gugu Mbatha-Raw as a
young homeless woman with emerging powers
she hasn't learned to control.
Don't expect this to be the last you see of
Fast Color on Amazon, either: In July 2019,
it was announced Amazon Studios is developing
an original series based on the film.
If you're eager for robot action, you'll be
able to stream 2018's Bumblebee starring Hailee
Steinfeld, Jorge Lendeborg Jr., and wrestler
John Cena on December 13.
Finally, on Dec. 30, Amazon will stream 2011's
action-packed Transformers: Dark of the Moon.
If you prefer your entertainment on the more
thrilling and terrifying side of things, Amazon
Prime Video has some new offerings in December
that might pique your interest.
On December 1, you can watch Denzel Washington
as tries to solve a murder before he becomes
the prime suspect in 2003's Out of Time.
That same day, the service will also offer
a couple of corny '70s horror flicks that
insect lovers should adore.
There's 1974's Phase IV, featuring an army
of sentient ants waging war on a desert's
human inhabitants.
And don't forget 1975's Bug, in which California
earthquakes unleash foot-long cockroaches
on the peaceful California city of Riverside.
On the ninth, watch Casey Affleck and Elisabeth
Moss struggle to survive a dying world in
the post-apocalyptic thriller Light of My
Life.
On Christmas Day, Prime Video begins streaming
2018's Night Hunter.
The psychological thriller stars Henry Cavill
as weathered Detective Walter Marshall tracking
down a serial killer that targets young women.
Ben Kingsley appears as a former judge turned
vigilante who's launching his own investigations,
while Alexandra Daddario] stars as criminal
profiler Rachel Chase.
Looking for a little drama?
On the first of the month, you can check out
2000's Almost Famous, which follows a teenager
who gets tapped to tour with the fictional
rock band Stillwater and write about the experience
for Rolling Stone magazine.
Plus, there's the 1987 John Hughes classic
Some Kind of Wonderful.
After that, you can cut loose and show your
rebellious dancing side by watching the 1984
hit Footloose.
Finally, you can watch Leonardo DiCaprio become
the legendary Howard Hughes in 2004's The
Aviator.
Amazon Prime Video is a little light on comedy
offerings in December, but its new arrivals
include one impressive standout – 1999's
Man on the Moon.
The biopic about the late Andy Kaufman is
named after the REM single "Man on the Moon,"
which paid tribute to the unorthodox comedian.
Jim Carrey plays Kaufman, in a performance
that saw him staying in character for much
of the film's production, both on and off
set.
Carrey won a Golden Globe for his efforts
and the film is largely regarded as the moment
any doubts that Carrey could excel as a "serious"
actor were dispelled.
While the actor made his bones playing absolutely
ridiculous characters like the lead of The
Mask and the Ace Ventura: Pet Detective films,
Carrey made great strides in the late 90s
to broaden his horizons.
His portrayal of a man who doesn't know he's
the subject of a lifelong reality series in
1998's The Truman Show convinced many moviegoers
Carrey could do more than straight comedy,
and Man on the Moon convinced many of the
stragglers.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.